New York is answering the growing calls
for police reform following the deadly
rest of George Floyd on Friday Governor
Andrew Cuomo signed a package of
accountability laws they include a ban
on police chokeholds and legislation to
allow the release of officers long
withheld disciplinary records the change
comes after the revelation that one of
the fired Minneapolis officers have been
accused of misconduct 17 times before
Floyd's death but the allegations of
excessive force went far beyond just one
officer and resulted in millions of
dollars in settlements Jeff the case has
that part of the story in 2012 Zach king
was leaving a Minneapolis nightclub when
he was stopped by the police he had a
handgun that he was legally permitted to
carry his I hate what's that bulge on
your on your waist I shot my hands I
hate I have a conceal and carry and
that's my gun my weapon and like six
officers just came from out of
everywhere and they got their knee on me
like almost like George Floyd I couldn't
breathe
King was hospitalized with a concussion
his face swollen with cuts and bruises I
didn't do anything to anybody and I was
violated King sued the department which
argued he didn't tell them he had a gun
permit until later he got a 122 thousand
dollar settlement ultimately who's
paying the tab for those settlements
residents of the city of Minneapolis
we've seen similar culture of abuse and
other large cities across the country
since 2003 Minneapolis has paid out
forty five million dollars in
settlements this year alone Los Angeles
has paid more than six million in
settlements Chicago more than 14 million
New York since 2015 more than a billion
dollars Zak Kings as it was officer
Joshua steward who led the assault
against him since the incident a CBS
News investigation found nine more
misconduct complaints have been made
against him none resulting in discipline
what do you make of that
his is pitiful his line is ridiculous
the Minneapolis Police Department told
CBS News that previous conduct and
nature of current offense
are factors that can be figured into
discipline King says not all police are
bad his little brother as a cop they
just need to be held accountable if you
sit back and watch your back hop do bad
stuff you're a bad cop two Minneapolis
PD still rebuilding its reputation after
George Floyd's death tell us that in the
Zach king case the officer at the center
of the case is still on the job and if
Derrick Chauvin is convicted in
connection with the death of George
Floyd he could still be eligible to
receive a pension that's worth more than
a million dollars receive yes this
morning Saturday Jeff buguese